-Our first guest tonight is
a talented actress who you know
from movies such as "Lady Bird"
and "Booksmart."
She stars as Fanny Brice in
"Funny Girl," which is playing
at the August Wilson Theater
on Broadway.
Please welcome back to the show
our friend Beanie Feldstein,
everybody.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hello, hello!
I'm so happy you're back.
-I'm so happy to be back.
And thank you so much
for that really beautiful,
very important conversation.
-I think, uh, you know, um --
Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you for giving
your platform.
-That's very nice of you
to say.
You look so well.
And I know that
you also are recovering
or you had to recover
from COVID.
-Yes. I just had COVID and I --
I truly don't know how I got it,
Seth.
I don't. I am the most paran--
Ask anyone who even walks by me
on the street.
They'd say,
"That Beanie, she's paranoid."
[ Laughter ]
The most paranoid person.
I'm in love with my mask.
I'm obsessed with my mask.
I'm obsessed with my boosters.
I don't know how it happened,
but it happened. But then --
-Did you make them test you
a second time
when it came back positive?
You're like, "This can't be."
-Unfortunately, I knew.
-You did? Oh, wow.
-It, like, hit me.
And then 10 days later, I was
back doing "Funny Girl,"
which is a three-hour,
like, marathon for me,
so it was a real, like,
zero-to-100 experience.
But I'm so grateful to be back
with my cast and my crew,
and we're just having
such a good time.
-And this is really, I mean,
you know,
there are some people who say,
"Oh, my God, 'Funny Girl'
is a dream role" or like,
"I can't believe
I'm playing this,"
but this really is
a dream role for you.
You had your third birthday.
-Third.
-Your third birthday
was "Funny Girl"-themed.
-Mm-hmm. Yeah.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It was. That's me.
[ Applause ]
And it's -- For me, it's like
I already had the po--
you know, the pose, too,
was already happening.
-I would say, like,
of all the girls who had
a "Funny Girl"-themed party,
it must be amazing to be the one
that's doing it on Broadway.
But I'm pretty sure
you're the only one.
-Yes, correct.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, I don't know.
Let me know
if they're out there.
But I think I'm prob--
At least the third birthday,
I'm probably the only one.
-Yeah, it's really amazing.
And it just must be --
it just must be joyous
to do it every night.
-It's a dream, you know.
Finally now
we're getting to interact with
people more at the stage door.
And we just have like mothers
bringing their daughters,
daughters bringing
their mothers, aunts.
It's such a warm room that we
get to enter into every night
and to be a part of telling
Fanny Brice's story as a --
as a Jewish comedian
and performer myself,
it's like I would not be here
if it wasn't for Fanny.
And so to get to embody her
every night with this,
like, delicious group
of people --
like, Seth, they're delicious.
They're delicious.
They're warm.
They're talented --
beyond talented.
The tap dancing in the show,
the --
you know, just the costumes.
It's just a delectable
little treat.
-I think that due to --
It's a weird thing.
Like, Fanny Brice almost seems
like a fictional character.
And I think a lot of people
don't know
she was a real person.
-So many people don't.
I mean, people think that --
some people --
Yeah, they don't know that
Barbra was playing a real person
and that I'm now
playing Fanny Brice.
And her legacy is for any Jewish
woman that wants to be on stage.
We would not have been there
if it wasn't for Fanny Brice
and the ceilings
that she knocked down
and the rooms
she pushed herself into.
She's like, "I'm a bagel
on a plate full of onion rolls,
watch me work."
[ Laughter ]
And it's very special
to get to embody that.
-You mentioned families,
you mentioned mothers
and daughters
and daughters and mothers.
Your mother, obviously,
came to opening night.
Has she come more than once?
-She's the queen of
the August Wilson Theater.
I think she --
I mean, people are more excited
to see her than me
when I walk in.
She's like, "Hello, it's me.
Yes, I'm Beanie's mother.
Hello."
I think she's seen it
like eight -- eight times.
-That's amazing.
-Maybe nine? I don't know.
-You can see the audience
in this show pretty well.
-I can see you all.
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
-I can see everybody.
-Do you like that?
-At first I was really scared.
-Yeah.
-And I didn't take it in,
I think for like all of previews
and opening.
But now I'm, you know --
we've been doing it
for a few months and --
and Fanny was so known for her
relationship to the audience.
So when I'm in the numbers
in the show
where she is performing,
I can really like let myself go.
-Does it throw you when
you have family in the audience,
when your mom's there?
Do you know where she's sitting?
-Yes. And it used to --
Again, it used to throw me.
And now I'm like...
[ Laughter ]
"Hi." Not during the emo--
In none of the emotional stuff,
I can't.
-Right.
-But when you know, uh --
-Well, it's about being
in the -- Yeah.
-Yeah. When she's on stage
I'm like, she's on stage.
-Yeah.
You had a birthday.
Was it Friday was your birthday?
-Yeah, it was, you know.
-Oh, well, happy birthday.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-The day the world went away.
-Yeah, right.
-Complicated day.
-Yeah, nobody really talked
about your birthday on Friday,
now that I think about it.
-No, um...
-Yeah, I did not see a CNN
breaking news --
"Beanie's birthday."
-Beanie's 29, very important.
-You also announced some pretty
cool news on Friday as well.
-I got engaged.
-You got engaged!
Beanie got engaged!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
You know, I think given
what's going on
in our country right now,
me marrying soon to be my wife,
Bon, Bonnie, but I call her Bon.
You know, I think it's really
important for us
to tell our story
and to live very proudly.
And I just love her
so much, Seth.
She's just the best thing
to ever happen to me.
-Congratulations.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And I know...
I want to -- Because I know
that you and Bon proposed --
you each proposed to each other.
But Bon put the work
in to sort of surprise.
-Yes.
She said to me early on,
she was like,
"I want to propose to you."
And I was like, "Okay."
-Yeah.
-I kind of wanted
to be proposed to.
So I was fine with it.
And so, I didn't know anything.
And this is when I was filming
"Impeachment:
American Crime Story."
So that was, for me, it was like
1998, I was in the White House,
I had no idea what was going on
in the real world.
I was so focused.
-Very easy to surprise
you during that time.
-Like, I was like, I only exist
with bangs on, like, you know.
It's only happening that way
for me playing Monica Lewinsky.
So I was really just entrenched
in my filming
and it made me completely
oblivious to everything.
Turns out everyone in my life
was lying to me.
Just literally
every single person
in my life was lying to me.
-So Bon reached out
to your family?
-Yes. And it was magical.
So she sent me, she was like,
"I think you need a break.
Why don't you go
to the beach for the day?"
So I went with my mom and
my brother and my best friend,
Ana, to the beach.
And then she was like,
"After, why don't we all meet up
at my parents' house
and we'll do something outside,
and why don't we all get dressed
up and it'll be really fun."
I was like, "Get dressed up?"
Like, "It's Saturday."
[ Laughter ]
I work all day.
I have to wear hair.
I'm like, "No." And they're
like, "Let's get dressed up."
And I was like,
"Okay, this is weird."
So we go to the beach,
and my parents' house
is like about 50 minutes,
an hour from where
we were at the beach.
And my mom -- I keep trying
to get her in the car
because we're going to be late.
And she's like, "I-I-I think
something's wrong with me."
[ Laughter ]
"I think something's wrong
with me."
And I was like, "What's wrong
with you?"
And she's like, "Oh, my stomach,
something's wrong with me!
Something's wrong with me."
And I was like, "Oh, okay."
We get in the car
and she's like,
literally like this
behind the wheel,
like this going five miles
an hour
on the Pacific Coast Highway.
And I'm like, "What is wro--
Do you want me to drive?"
Like, "I'll get you
home faster."
She's like, "Oh, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no.
I'm gonna drive,
I'm gonna drive."
Then she's, literally --
I was like, "Is she gonna
Maya Rudolph in 'Bridesmaids'
the situation
and just, like, cross PCH
and poop
in the middle of the street?"
Like, I was like, "What is
happening right now?"
Because she just kept screaming
that it was going to happen.
And she pulls over on the side.
We finally get off the highway.
She pulls over in West L.A.,
runs into a random restaurant,
just takes off running.
I'm like, "What is happening?"
She gets back in the car.
Finally, we pull up
to my parents' house
and my nephews are standing
in the driveway
and they're teenagers
and they're wearing little
matching shirts.
And I get out of the car.
I'm like,
"What are you guys doing here?"
They weren't supposed to be
at the gathering
and they're like,
"Hi, Aunt Beanie."
And they, like,
won't look me in the eye.
And I'm like, "What?
What are you --
What's happening?"
My youngest nephew, Charlie,
reaches into his pocket.
This is when I start to cry.
And he pulls out my ring for Bon
that I had gotten months ago.
Because I wanted
to be prepared in case --
-Yeah.
-And he goes, "I think
you're gonna need this."
-Aw!
[ Audience aws ]
-Can you just --
I can't handle it.
And I start screaming.
I'm like, "Am I getting
engaged?!"
[ Laughter ]
And Bon said she could
hear it from the backyard.
And I walk out.
-There we go.
Look at that.
Bon, well done, Bon!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Very well done.
-So the first thing -- so sweet.
So, we literally --
She proposes to me then she
doesn't know I have the ring.
I propos-- I get down
on one knee, I propose back.
She's so shocked, she goes,
"Uh, okay?"
[ Laughter ]
That was her response.
Very loving.
And we kiss, we hug.
And the first thing
as an engaged person
that I whisper in Bon's ear is,
"My mom -- My mom almost pooped
on the side of the road."
And she goes, "It was all a lie
to make sure
you didn't get here early."
And I was like,
"My mom deserves an Oscar."
I was like, "This is
literally the best."
And I've worked with
some amazing people, Seth.
It was the best performance
I'd ever seen in my life.
-So, wait, even pulling over
at a restaurant and running in?
-Fake.
-Wow!
-She's so committed.
-Are you --
-And she's also, I guess,
afraid of Bon, because she knew
she couldn't be here early.
-Now, are you moving forward?
Are you ever going to be able
to trust your mother again
knowing that
she's that good a liar?
-No.
-Yeah.
-It's gone for me now.
-That's very --
-I didn't know she had it
in her, Seth, let me tell you.
-That is shocking.
-And it was extraordinary work.
Extraordinary work.
I was like, "I need
to take some notes."
-You mentioned Maya Rudolph.
You were recently
a bridesmaid as well.
And you would
argue the harder job.
-Yes. Now that I'm engaged,
I'm going to be a bride --
Being maid of honor
is like this weird superpower.
Like, that you're like,
"I'm the maid of honor."
And they're like,
"Right this way."
You're like,
"This is incredible."
So I was the maid of honor in my
best friend Melanie's wedding.
And it was at this beautiful
hotel right outside of L.A.
And my parents
were also invited,
and my mom calls me.
I'm with Melanie, getting ready,
and she's like,
"You won't guess who I ran into
at the breakfast.
Kristen Wiig and her family
are here.
And I was like, she's my --
You know.
-Yes, I know.
-No offense, Seth.
-No, I'll take it.
-She is my everything.
And I was like, "Oh, my God,
I can't believe this.
That's insane." But I was with
the bride all day.
So I, you know,
focused on that, like,
you know, "Tell her I said hi."
-You're not allowed
even as a --
As a maid of honor,
you're not allowed to be like,
"I gotta bounce."
-You can't leave to go see
Kristen Wiig.
-"Kristen Wiig's here.
I gotta go."
-You have to focus
on the bride, it's imperative.
So we're lining up,
and the wedding is in the middle
of the beautiful hotel,
and we're lining up.
And I'm last before Melanie,
the gorgeous bride
and my best friend.
And I'm stepping out to go
literally walk down the aisle
and I see Kristen and her family
and they're waiting
because they don't want to run
in the middle of the ceremony.
And I'm wearing my mask
and I'm like -- pull it down,
I'm like [Whispering] "Kristen!
It's Beanie!"
And I was like,
"I'm a bridesmaid!"
And she starts laughing.
I'm in a pink dress.
I was like, "This is the best
moment of my life!"
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, my God!"
I don't think
you understand, like,
we grew up on that.
Like, that movie came out
my senior year of high school.
It is like the reason I wanted
to be an actor.
It is like my everything.
And so to be wearing
a pink bridesmaid's dress,
in front of Kristen Wiig,
I was like, "I'm done.
I see ya.
This will be better
than my wedding.
Sorry, Bon."
-I just want to say something.
This keeps happening to you.
-Am I, like, amazing?
I'm amazing at manifesting.
-Whatever outfit you wear,
you like, summon the fortune.
You have a deep-cut favorite
Kristen Wiig sketch.
And I have a lot
of respect for it.
And your brother Jonah Hill
was in the sketch.
-But it's not about him.
Let's just be clear.
-No, he's a prop.
-He's a literal prop.
He's being objectified,
as he should be.
Kristen Wiig as Liza Minnelli.
-Yeah.
-You know, I love a diva.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, you love a diva.
-I love a diva.
-I'm pretty sure there's maybe
no dialogue.
There's very little dialogue
in the sketch.
-Maybe three lines?
-And it's great.
It's called "Liza Minnelli
turns on a lamp"?
-Turns off -- Turns off a lamp?
-Turns off a lamp,
you're right, yeah.
-Turns off a lamp, I think.
Like, your generation of
"Saturday Night Live" was my --
-They were A-listers.
That cast, they were A-listers.
-And it was
when I was a teenager.
So for me, it was just like
my comedy handbook.
-Yeah.
-And you all --
-I was very lucky
to sort of just be nearby
while that was all happening.
-No, that's not --
Take more credit.
-I was just sitting there,
just like the first act
of our show.
I just sit here.
[ Laughter ]
-It's important
for you to listen.
-I'm a good listener.
-You are a good listener.
-That's what they say,
out of everybody
in show business,
I'm the best listener.
-You are a good listener.
[ Laughter ]
-But there's, I mean, like
the second place is so far --
Nobody's a good listener
in show business.
It's very easy.
I'm so happy you were here
tonight of all nights
and congratulations again
on your engagement.
-Thank you so much.
-You guys,
that's Beanie Feldstein.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Funny Girl" is playing
at the August Wilson Theatre.
We'll be right back
with Matthew Modine.